hello this is Adam from Playstation
grenade today I've been challenged to
complete this out assassin suit only
achievements from the silvers bonus
mission from hitman 2016 my task is to
kill the lead actor and director of this
film that's been shot in Sapienza and
they wanted the same person
by the looks of it looks like I'm
getting Robert Downey jr. in his Iron
Man persona so let's do this and by the
way if you're hearing this it means I'm
successful so yay me woo well done
anyway right if you want to do the
mission the same way as me what you need
is the remote explosive duck yes you
heard me right I'm choosing this because
if you are seen throwing an explosive
everyone reports it to the police but if
you are seen throwing a rubber duck you
just look a bit mental and which is what
we're going for I've noticed from my six
previous attempts to this one that when
the explosive goes off the actors on set
stop completely
but the animatronics continue so if all
goes well the bipedal monster thing will
run over the actor and thus create the
perfect accident that's the plan anyway
I need a spot to roll this duck which
won't hurt anyone because we only want
to kill one actor maybe on the roof Oh
in fact look though we can put behind
the AV truck that we perfect right let's
get into position and wait for the
director to show action
oh yes it stopped come on running over
come on yes yes yes that barely
scratched him but we did it
no completed quicker skip run it legging
let's go go go oh I almost forgot the
duck remote explosive either unlocked
during the episode three Marrakesh
mission you'll need to get to mastery
level 15 to get you pretty paws on it
but it's definitely worth it you know
what I think I've done this mission
accomplished
South assassin soup only and no evidence
the perfect assassination oh and five
stars or pitman logo things too so
you've seen it with your own eyes that's
how it's done if you enjoyed this please
like comment share and subscribe and
I'll see you again for more Hitman
brutality really soon
[Music]